right okay so this is very very awkward
welcome to this welcome to this talk
which I've given eight times this talk
works much better with a larger audience
alright so now it's just become me
bitching to twelve people or less okay
so bear with me if and I'll give you
these little disclaimers and and someone
just turned around and said I'm not
putting up with that crap right quickly
this famous this is not going to be
informative it's not gonna be
thought-provoking it's not going to be
into entertaining it sure as hell isn't
gonna be inspirational okay so honestly
if you're here for any of those things
just leave go next door John is doing an
awesome talk on six sharp seven alright
this is me literally just pissed off and
ranting about life okay so if you're up
for that steak this is me I normally
don't talk about myself I literally
don't and I hate people that say I don't
normally talk about myself in a talk and
then they go on for five minutes talking
about themselves I don't normally talk
about myself but it's to give you a
little bit of context okay this is me
when I was two years old I was born in
Iran my mother said we're moving to
Spain I myself and I got into
computers and I became extremely grumpy
okay and so kind of like everyone here
I'm background to this talk because
everything there's a Y in everything and
Greg a friend of mine Greg young he said
the guy that did the CQRS event sourcing
great guy very smart he said how'd he
come to build stuff build stuff is a
conference in Lithuania in which you
learn a lot of things and you do a lot
of things that stay in Lithuania and he
said but and I said but what he said you
have to give a talk on wucf right so
that's kind of like getting a wedding
invitation that you've so long wanted to
go for to go to and saying I finally
made it on the list once in my life
opening it up and seeing this instead of
the address right and you think to
yourself like why why would I want to go
why would he
on me in this sense why would he say
that you have to talk about WCF I wrote
a book on wucf wait that's not the worst
part
I wrote it in Spanish right and I'm in
Spain we've got a good habit of reading
we're very cultured we just don't know
you can pay for books so on top of the
fact that you don't make much money on
books I got a lot of people to read it
it's unfortunately every time you do WCF
hadi i still show up and I'm trying to
get Google to forget me but it's not
working out well because they say why
they don't understand the involvement
here but getting back to WCF now how
many of you here have done WCF brilliant
it was brilliant right yes and before
that there was Corbin if you remember
CORBA before that at the same time of
Cobra there was Midas any Delphi people
here so I used to do Delphi and there
was this thing called Midas and the only
screenshot I found was ironically in
Russian and my this was a great
technology that allows you to do
distributed computing and it came around
the same time as decom right which is
calm and my and Microsoft said let let
me screw you even more in a distributed
fashion so there was calm there was D
calm there was poor brother that was
Midas and then one day came this great
unification right and this great
unification was this new programming
model that's what's gonna save us it was
absolutely brilliant right it was a
unified model for all communication
needs it compiled it complied with the
four pillars of solar now these four
pillars of solar from dawn box who at
the time happened to be working for
Microsoft who was the person behind WCF
same company it didn't comply with the
eleven pillars of saw by Thomas Earle
but that's okay as long as it complies
with those four pillars it was great and
it was sold to us as a silver bullet
right and they said to us it's easy as
ABC a standard for the address which
means where you want to talk to be
standing for the binding which means how
you want to talk and see was a contract
which means what exactly were you going
to talk okay and you could configure it
at runtime
now back there and we didn't have fancy
JSON we had XML right and it had like
its configuration options which doesn't
fit on one screen or two screens you
to give you some perspective those were
the options and they said if you build
it it will run now the key thing there
was you have to learn to configure it
first but if you did that it would run
and we used to go around including
myself obviously I wrote a book about it
so I'm gonna promote that this is this
thing and I went around and saying this
is fantastic and it's brilliant and it
works but things started to fail and
then you know what happened they said
your issue is WCF right WCF is overly
complicated it's adding a lot of
overhead that is not required and those
promises were not delivered and you're
like but you just came in and told me to
rewrite this damn thing using WCF and
now you're telling me that it's not it's
not valid someone had the bright idea of
saying every class should be a service
and we all just kind of facepalm at that
point and it all went to hell so the
Silver Bullet was not delivered and the
rest is history as you well know okay
now if you've not used WCF if the one
thing that's been holding you back about
using WCF is that it's not open source
you'll be glad to know that it's now
open source on github so go right ahead
and adopt it and it wouldn't be fair of
me to pick on Microsoft despite being
more of Microsoft conferences because
Java had it - and you know what they say
with Java you have a problem use Java
now you have a problem Factory and we
were in a we were in a conference in in
in in Paris and I was we were doing like
the speaker Cruz thing along the boat
and I was up there taking a picture of
the Eiffel Tower and Antonio Conte Levis
who's a who's a big Java 2e guy you know
he comes up to me and he's like oh you
know never with his French accent never
in history has a man created something
so horrible and useless which is utter
nonsense because there is Java to EE so
you know and Java has its own fair share
of things and it's been criticized
heavily like you know we have fizzbuzz
Enterprise Edition right if you know
fizzbuzz there is an Enterprise Edition
which pulls down half of the Internet
and then came along spring spring said
let's build a better Enterprise right
spring is a new framework that's 12
years old that said let's build it
better and
surprising let's make things better and
then they came up with things like this
which is an actual class from spring
called abstract singleton proxy factory
beam now that manual I'm not making it
up actually says that this is a
convenient proxy factory being
superclass for proxy factory beans that
create only Singleton's that is the
description of this class right but
there is hope for distributed computing
and you all know what I know mean it's
called micro-services now if you're not
familiar with micro-services it's a
bunch of little things working together
to join something big so it's kind of
like doing a lot of little so us except
you feel small you fell often and you
fail a lot or as I like to say you move
from a single ball of mud to
orchestrating a lot of ok and a
good friend of mine Simon Brown said you
know he kept saying that if you can't
build monoliths properly you sure as
hell aren't gonna be able to build good
micro-services but this has given way to
us having conversations like how many
lines is a microservice you know it's
not even about classes anymore because
classes of someone's that every class
should be a service so consequently
multiple methods should constitute a
micro service fortunately for us tools
can help and this is a prototype I've
been working on for IntelliJ which
allows you to select some code and
extract the micro service ok if you
don't know how to implement a micro
service there's already a draft by na
ist that tells you exactly what a
Microsoft service is in 670 pages and if
you are worried that micro service isn't
the next big thing it is because if you
go to micro services org it redirects to
IBM therefore it's already mainstream
but I'm joking because micro services is
a thing of the past
ok the future as you know is serverless
it's called Cerberus architecture take
notes okay it is turbulence architecture
and I read a blog post that they said
how they decided to use Cerberus nano
services architecture with AWS to make
happy right how many of you are familiar
with Cerberus architectures right it
basically means put all of my
dependencies in a hand of a single
vendor but it's it's quite cool and
they're telling us that that is actually
a silver bullet
now I've been talking a lot about
computing and distributed computing and
that and it's not only an issue with
distributed computing we've also had
this issue with data persistence in the
early days we all wrote our doubts how
many of you are familiar with what $1
it's a data access there and then
someone came along and said oh RMS are
much better and you know we had
hibernate in hibernate so what did we
all do at that point we wrote our own
ORM we didn't use the existing ones
because we could do it better so we
wrote our own ORM and then we came up
with all of these different options and
then at some point we said no maybe we
should just give in and use a an
existing ORM and at that point in order
to save our bacon what we decided to do
was create abstractions around these ORM
s so that we will never be locked into
an ORM and that way we wouldn't get the
benefits of the ORM and we would add a
whole bunch of nonsense for nothing how
many of you created abstractions how
many of you moved oh RMS in a single
project yeah there you go at some point
someone said oh RMS are bad and they
said that you need to separate your
rights from your reads they said now if
you're not familiar with CQRS initially
when you used to Google CQRS Google was
response and did you mean cars
no I meant CQRS which stands for command
and query responsibility segregation
CQRS how many are you doing it it's
brilliant right and if you don't do if
you do secure us you have to do event
sourcing because otherwise it's not cool
and of course you can't do any of these
things if you don't do domain driven
design but at the end of the day we
realized that it was nothing about this
it wasn't about date access layers it
wasn't about our it was nothing about
this
it was the actual underlying storage
mechanism that was an issue and we were
all very familiar with the sequel model
and we all loved the sequel model and
then along came this thing called no
sequel no sequel was fantastic it told
you how you can store things right and
depending on the model that you were
choosing you could store things or for
example you could not store things and
they said to us that this was a silver
bullet right and they said this is the
problem you need to move away from
sequel server to something like a
document database some of us as some
points some of them at some point I
always include this as myself as well
because I've been through all of this
crap and I've said all of this crap as
well we decided that it's not anything
to do them with that it's the actual
platform that's the problem okay
and normally when people said that your
platform sucks they said your community
sucks too so there's a dotnet version of
this slide which is called dotnet sucks
nodejs is great okay how many of you
have heard that before okay there's a
Java version which is the JVM sucks no
js' is great now unfortunately for the
note folks it already sucks because go
is great go is the next thing and then
you get blog posts and articles in very
prominent magazines that says why Google
go program is going to rival Java in the
enterprise of course if you look back
three months you get the same thing
about how Java is gonna die because of
nodejs and normally when people complain
about this and they moan about the
platform they do it in the form of a
blog post right and they say I'm leaving
Java or I'm leaving Garnett and it they
blurb about a lot of things but you
there's some keywords that you can
identify in that blog post which is too
much ceremony scale I need scale I need
enterprise I don't need enterprise and
you don't help each other that is very
very common pattern that you come across
and then they make announcements like
you know I've moved to node and our
productivity is increased tenfold of
course nobody actually sat down to
measure that productivity or see if it
had increased tenfold
but you know it does enable us to again
say things like we now ship micro
services using docker lining our
technology stack with our business needs
all this made possible with go yes some
CTO somewhere and some of us of course
realized a change in platform didn't
really work because it was really our
our code that was the problem and it
wasn't our code because technically we
rewrote that code in a different
platform so maybe it was a potentially
us so you know the the platform wasn't
the Silver Bullet either because the
quality didn't improve and talking about
quality how many of you do unit testing
did you all go through this phase of I
used to actually just ship code and get
paid for it and then they said test it
no screw you and then I decided to oh no
this unit testing thing is actually
quite nice and some
in my life I decided to unittest
absolutely everything and then they said
that isn't enough you have to combine
these unit tests in creating
permutations and then you got to do
integration tests and at some point I
realize that I'm not shipping code
anymore so I stopped doing unit testing
and right now I'm about somewhere here
right and you know when we were doing
unit testing a few came along and said
you're doing it wrong because it's you
got to do TDD it's red green refactor if
you don't do TDD you're not doing proper
design therefore it's not good then
there was another tendency which was
called BDD behavior driven development
by Dan North he coined the term and he
said it's about communications right
it's about communicating and talking to
people what did we do as developers we
thought it was about frameworks and we
came up with different frameworks and
then we said it's brilliant because now
my framework might my customer can write
the tests and I just implement things
and I don't even have to talk to them
yes we did that as well so the problem
is the paradigm now apparently they're
telling us a lot of a lot of things that
you're hearing is that it's actually
about the the paradigm that we're
following in why we're not accomplishing
this success and this silver bullet that
they've been promising us now how many
of you have read this book right a few
years ago I remember blog post by Jeff
Atwood in which he had claimed that he'd
haven't read this book and everyone said
you are crazy how can you call yourself
a software engineer if you've not read
this book nowadays if you say you
reading this book they'll frown on you
and say are you for real are you still
doing object-oriented programming
because nowadays it's all about
functional programming right it's
recently I heard a tweet come through
saying the functional programming is a
radical new paradigm it was by someone
from JavaScript community there was only
invented seventy-five years ago but and
as you know there's only one way to do
functional programming which is you see
I'm in a dotnet car of course you can
say F sharp you know how you know an
application is written in F sharp now
because our bloody tell you this
no it's Haskell right but actually
talking about F sharp I came across a
really good tweet the other day that
said functional programming and F sharp
helps jet raise 500 million dollars for
VC Congrats jet technology
points to a blog post on TechCrunch that
didn't say a word about F sharp or
programming or anything but apparently F
sharp
you know the VC came and said what are
you using C sharp or F sharp F sharp
there you go here's 500 million dollars
right because that's how VC is invest
mind you having said that it might be
the case did you recently hear about all
those VC people that invested in
Nintendo only to find out that pokemon
gold wasn't written by Nintendo and the
stocks came crashing yeah it does
explain a lot of startup ideas but
fortunately for us the future is bright
and if you can see it's JavaScript right
and JavaScript is productive how many of
you like javascript right
we have node javascript is fantastic if
you're not familiar with node remember
all of that crap that we wrote on the
client-side now we can write it on the
server side as well that's what node is
about and node was doing really really
well for some time and then at some
point someone forked node right now
think about what just happened an open
source project on github got forked and
all hell broke loose right and then you
saw tweets like if you're stuck on
legacy technology like nodejs only two
weeks after he got forked two weeks
right people were using the new one and
nodejs was there was legacy technology
fortunately for all of us they all made
up and were friends again
in fact Wired magazine didn't even
bother changing the graphic because you
can look at that as a fork and as a
reunification and it was all good
everyone was happy and then Microsoft
came along and said we're forking node
now note and node enables JavaScript on
the server but it's not JavaScript the
language itself that was designed in a
week that's so productive but the entire
ecosystem that is around note I mean
you've all heard of NPM right NPM is the
package manager for node if you stay
long enough on that website it also says
that it's the package manager for power
which if you don't know what it is it's
a package manager ok and you've got 1.5
billion people having downloaded these
packages and you've got over half a
million packages on there with very good
discoverable names those are actual
names like testacular Jas happy
whatever
yes in fact shai had come up with a game
where you think of a noun Google's a
noun and if it exists as a package you
drink and I promise you you will get
drunk okay now recently what happened in
the node ecosystem was that one
developer broke the entire world because
he pulled the package he deleted a
package from the NPM repository called
left pad which was basically 11 lines of
code packaged up there was more lines of
code for packaging it than the actual
code itself this is the actual code
right and when this happened I started
to look around and I started to think
like is there a package really this
small and I'd dug deeper and deeper and
in fact I found a package which is
called is array which tells you if
something is an array this has had 18
million downloads last month it has 72
packages that depend on it and it
actually fits in this tweet right this
is what we've created and I enter the
debate with someone on Twitter and you
know I said you know like ok copy
pasting code from Stack Overflow was one
thing and the response was why should I
copy paste code from Stack Overflow if I
can just search for that functionality
and install it this is what we've
created right let's just npm install and
bundle everything together and call it
productivity and I started to look more
and I found is negative is positive is
zero negative which I don't know what it
is but it's apparently a variation of
negative is is there a positive is array
is not array is false is something like
array and has identity crisis
which I contributed fortunately for us
some people saw this as a major problem
and also soared as business opportunity
and they created left pad as a service
so in case anyone pulls down left pad
you can always go to the service and
it's available with an SLA ok and as I
say why search on Stack Overflow when
you can do NPM search development from
now on right I'll give you an example of
how bad it is that you can actually do
fizzbuzz using packages in JavaScript ok
now javaScript again with all these
packages it also provides us with very
very good excellent frameworks how many
of you have heard anger about angularjs
right it's it's awesome and I want to
place emphasis on the bi and the Google
which apparently means that they give
you some guaranteed upgrade
compatibility or something like that
how many of you migrated from one to two
and I've lived to tell it no there's
still probably somewhere in a basement
trying to migrate so when this happened
what I did is I used to use angular and
I said screw this I'm jumping on the
react bandwagon right react.js from
Facebook fantastic and I went to the
react website and behold by my surprise
I found a new button that's a
compatibility certificate and I clicked
on it and it said react is is going to
be compatible backwards compatible
obviously I'm being sarcastic here and
little bit joking but my point was that
a lot of people complained that you will
never have this problem with react right
this was only a specific problem with
angularjs until I came across this post
which says upgrading from react zero
point eleven point two to zero point
fourteen point seven and three hundred
and seventy four easy steps right they
did they solved our problem with
angularjs they call everything RC and RC
if you remember back in the old days
mint release candidate which meant we're
not going to change anything until
really hell breaks loose and we put this
from Bad bug now it's just kind of a new
version right and and when you reproach
Microsoft for doing it they're like well
look at what the angular team is doing
so WordPress was rewritten in note and
react.js open sourced against VPS will
be P stands for vice-president this is
huge is this end of PHP as a major
language this is this is the the
knee-jerk reactions that we get in our
industry well in the world and then we
we had react native which they told us
that this is a game changer and this
time it really does change everything
no really it does and react and react
native native are are kind of more like
a library approach right so they're not
framework they don't lock you into the
framework and they come up with this
thing called a flux architecture which
basically you have a web api that talks
to web api you to
interacts with action creators that goes
to act with actions that dispatcher then
has callbacks store and then there's
some events and react fuse and but it's
really nicely decoupled it's fantastic
now some people realize this and they
said this is bad so they came up with a
different one which they called reflux
unfortunately I didn't find the logo for
it this is the best thing that I found
and I very much liked this tweet which
shows us 12 years of progress in web
development right I remember those days
and now look at it we have created so
much crap over development thinking that
we're making it simple right
but no it's not about simplicity it's
about scalability in terms of
maintainability yes but by the time you
know what one of the best things that we
have as developers is that we create
something and then we move on and we say
to hell with that whoever comes next
will maintain it right so but they say
that this is the Silver Bullet but if
you don't like angularjs you don't like
react you just have to wait one day
before the Internet will see a new
framework of JavaScript ok
and one of these new things was the
birth of isomorphism if how many of you
have heard of isomorphism so basically
this is how the story went server-side
rendering wasn't smooth back in 2000 and
someone said let's do this client-side
but client-side was very hard because it
was called JavaScript and they said well
why don't we create a framework and then
someone said you've lost your SEO right
and they said let's create another
framework and that's isomorphism which
renders the same thing on the client
side and the server side because why
because we can and but there's six
reasons why are some morphic web apps is
not the Silver Bullet you're looking for
oh well but too bad but let's go a
little bit back to basics and that's you
know if you if you don't like any of
these frameworks there is a there's an
alternative for you which is called um
vapor ojs it's a it's a JavaScript
framework and believe it or not that's
just an empty tag but it's got something
like last time I checked eight hundred
and twelve stars and 190 Forks on github
now judging that we adopt technology
github stars and forks told you quite a
bit right but there is hope there is
hope because as you know typescript
language team visited Google and now we
have everything in typescript no more
JavaScript the death of JavaScript I for
one vouch for that let it go and become
a dying virtual machine but getting back
to reacting about naming things we are
also beyond the whole functional
programming we are now reactive right
it's all about reactive programming
especially in the Java world that
they've just discovered reactive
extensions and it's about the only thing
that we contributed back to the to the
Java community and don't call it
functional reactive programming because
it's not about that and what do we do as
developers when we create a new paradigm
or we discover some new technology what
is the first thing that we do even
before creating the framework for it now
we don't tweet it we create a manifesto
and we say that everybody should be
reactive and all applications should be
scalable and all applications to be
resilient and reliable and now it
actually makes sense for me to say
something like I'm developing a
functionally reactive restful micro
service and I'm writing in an Rx
CoffeeScript which is a flavor of rx
Java for CoffeeScript building it with
grunt and shipping in and docker and it
makes absolute sense and dr. world
because containers are the thing now and
in my view the only way that we could
guarantee working software is that it
works on my machine so screw it let's
just ship my machine as a container
right but it allows us to move really
really quickly okay so but dr. is the
silver bullets until someone comes along
and says no it's not and let's not
forget that we're just building docker
images on things that are put up in the
docker registry that we don't know what
exactly is in that image or what
security potential holes it might have
or what legal potential holes they might
have but it's so awesome ok but building
software is actually hard and we've
discovered this through make tools which
we've tried to look for this silver but
it is well first of all there was make
how many of you familiar would make we
paid basically everyone used make and
then there was ant and in the Java world
and then we adopted as as Nance and then
in the Java world came maven and
kind of like died and that was the point
when you started a new project and it
was like pulling down the entire
internet and we inherited that with
Newgate and with NPM as well we kind of
like to do that and then someone said
Ruby and someone else said oh that's
expressive and someone said DSL and then
it just went to hell right
you know raike was born which was a ruby
make which was a little bit more
expressive and then the JVM got Gradle
dotnet got passaic cake and fake which
apparently fake is the best one and do
you know what javascript got it got Jake
but they didn't dare is Jake
but they didn't have enough with Jake so
they came up with grunt which really
requires 670 dependencies to output one
file into another folder but someone
said grunt is really ugly so I'll come
up with gulp which is fantastically high
P and if building software is hard what
is even harder is building scalable
software and we've come up with what I
call Silicon Valley syndrome which is if
you are building software you needed to
scale it doesn't matter if it's for a
single individual or whatever you need
it to scale and you know who tells you
these all of those wonderful cloud
providers that give you what scalability
right but you're like no it's just for
you know the corner shop it doesn't
matter scale you just turn a knob move
that dial it's scales right and
everything we do it needs to scale now
if you're not into the software stuff
new doors have opened for us right and
it is now micro services but the
Internet of Things now that is the
Raspberry Pi connected to my toilet ok
it was a mock-up that I did and I and
and the idea behind that was that I can
sit face forward on my toilet sorry too
much information and tweet the flusher
you know hadees flasher and hadees
flasher and then that would flush my
toilet so I wouldn't have to turn around
right you know changing the world and I
tweeted that as a mock-up and someone
the first response was how do you make
sure that the cable doesn't get wet
right
sorry I gotta take a moment here
there's no glasses okay um and if that's
not your thing
DevOps should be to your thing because
apparently empathy is something that you
can tool hire and certify on okay and if
you're not into DevOps don't worry it's
already dead because managed services
are killing them and finally of course
all of these silver bullets and all of
these issues that we already had we
lived through them in parallel with
something else which was called
methodology okay oh thank you so much
that's very kind of you
whiskey in it so the methodology I'm
sure you all remember waterfall yes
because it sucked scrum is the new
waterfall right and scrum now we're
evaluating what exactly we're doing with
scrum and whether we are doing stand-ups
now in slack and sit-ups to keep meeting
short there was an article that said you
actually do sit-ups while you're in your
scrum meeting to keep it short
right and it's fantastic now last I
checked lean doesn't suck but that was
only about two hours ago so you might
want to check that out before you adopt
lean but if you really think about it we
are geniuses seriously we are absolute
geniuses because by and large what we've
actually done is create a
self-sustaining industry right I've
created what's called the IT life cycle
new technology comes out we recommend it
then we sell it we provide training for
it normally in the in the in a way of
two days certificates you know you
become certified whatever and then we
implement it we put it into production
and then the customer calls are saying
something's gone wrong and guess what we
have a new technology right and the
circle just goes round and round now it
would be kind of hypocritical for me to
stand up here and you know say that this
is consultants and developers and
trainers and all that we all have tool
in this game because guess what we tool
it for you at Jeffrey's right so we
offer you all of that and on now on top
of that we have offered on subscription
basis ok and if you look at the
technology lifecycle what happens is
that we nowadays you create a new
framework then you create a conference
around this framework and then
go to ten right that's basically what
happens and it could be a framework it
could be a technology remember Cerberus
architectures this conference was in May
and it sold out over a thousand people
some of us don't even know what Cerberus
means but it's awesome
but unfortunately the honeymoon is going
to be over soon
because it's called machine learning and
in that point we're all gonna die we're
gonna be out of jobs
that's it I mean we're done Facebook is
releasing a whole bunch of bots
and apparently it says that it wants to
use the bots to kind of like interact
with you like you interact with your
friends I only discovered like I quit
Facebook cuz I didn't have any friends
I'm so you know maybe the four that I
had war bots and anyway at this point I
will shut up and stop right and you're
probably gonna ask okay blah blah blah
you've made fun of everything and
anything that's under the Sun you've had
a nice laugh what is your point I don't
have any point right I don't like but I
do buy it but you can't reproach me
about this you can't give me a red card
because when you came in I said you're
not gonna learn anything it's not
informative it's not bloody entertaining
and it sure as hell is an inspiration
I've just said that we're all bloody
bastards in a sense right including me
what is my point there is no point there
is actually one point if you didn't know
there is no silver bullet right other
than that I don't really have a point
but let me just step back a second say
like okay so why the hell are we
constantly jumping on to new
technologies all the time why why are we
doing this right and to answer that
question we've got to step back right so
let's step back and say why did we get
into software development and this is
where I turn it over to you and ask you
my dear friends why did you get into
software development who got into this
for the money what you're doing
sharepoint but apart from that who else
who got into it because they like to
automate stuff challenging solving
problems potentially even helping people
once you realize that it was fun and oh
and I can actually help people get stuff
done better
I can automate stuff so that people have
more free time with their children and
to go out and take
long walks and we at some point we
didn't know when to stop because we're
actually automating people out of a job
and a sample will automate ourselves out
of a job but that's another conversation
to have over whiskey
but none of us got into this for
software right or let alone none of us
got into this because they said you know
what I love doing writing some code and
spending the rest of my life upgrading
to new frameworks that's what I like to
do right now we've got a really really
really high technology churn I mean
while I have been here on stage there's
probably a new framework that's come out
right and a new paradigm um the reality
is that we can't always be on the latest
and greatest it's kind of like you know
I'm not gonna buy a laptop because I'm
gonna wait until the prices go down and
get a better spec it's it you'll always
end up with you know not ever buying
anything but you say no what we're doing
we're actually innovating right what are
we doing with all of these new
technologies and things we're innovating
we're finding new ways to improve and I
tell you that that is great innovation
improvement is good and I'm very serious
about that because I've put this in
Comics ons in red what I've done it on
purpose so if there's one slide you
remember it's that one but what exactly
are we actually improving right so when
we're adopting these new frameworks
technologies etc what exactly are we
improving and what is the business value
that it is adding by adopting these
things right and when I say business
value I don't mean BDD okay or forget
business value how exactly does it bring
value to us right and how are we making
these technological choices do we use
reasoning like you know well walmart has
moved to no js' therefore Walmart's big
Walmart successful I'm going to move to
no js' why not or are we influenced by
thought leaders or technology radars or
industry or speakers coming up on stage
and saying WCF is great I'm sorry about
that
I really am I made two mistakes in my
life one of them was that and the other
one was recommending angularjs so you
know when we listen to these people do
we
take into account whether we have the
same needs as them do we have the same
needs as Walmart or Google or Netflix
right do the same conditions apply when
we listen to these scalability factors
and these micro services and these
orchestration and all of these different
technologies because you see one time
one thing that we usually forget is
context and context is a really really
important word you know we don't always
have those same needs a technological
choice applies in a certain specific
context when it matches certain
conditions and maybe their needs aren't
the same as our needs it's exactly like
best practices you know best practices
aren't always best practices they depend
on when and where so then how do we make
these technological choices there's
actually like is it technological driven
right technology driven design you know
there's a website that you can go and
put random crap together and say I built
this and you're like why like why did
you connect Kafka to whatever
well because it's cool but why do you
need it because I need it
a logger for what well ok nevermind um
you know do we take into account
technology stability stability is it
proven technology what is the learning
curve for this technology what is the
market share for this technology do we
take any of those things into account
and do we really evaluate costs how many
times when we've had to create a new
edition or extension or whatever to our
application or even implement and you
want do we ever think down and say sit
down and say you know what let me break
down the cost of rewriting this versus
extending right do we ever do that
no new shiny right and then do we
validate our investment yeah with the
new nodejs conversion we're saving 3
hours a day
Rini did you actually measure that and
by the way did you lose 6 months when
they pulled left pad because if things
go bad we're not Google or Facebook
right we're burning money I mean they
burn money as well but they got a little
bit more money than we got right well I
don't know
I'm assuming some of you might have more
but and what's important doesn't impact
our pay how many of you your boss or
manager or whoever if you're working for
an employer comes to you and says you
know how you chose angularjs bad choice
I'm gonna cut your salary this month
not really right it doesn't impact our
pay does it no so what do we have to
lose we're learning in the process
what do we have to lose ah
ghosts our wall we'll do it again right
and that's caused by a financial
impedance mismatch right and that's why
I say that every developer at some point
in their lives should set up their own
business and really start to evaluate
decisions based on exactly why they're
making them not just because it's
beautiful because if it doesn't bring
value to the business why the hell are
we doing it right and are we actually
confusing our desire to learn with
business value oh I want to learn
something new I could use this
technology in this new project and why
not you know we're just chasing that new
shiny our decisions actually CV based
are we doing CV driven design right and
of course a lot of this is not our own
fault because there's social pressure
you know there's I mean I've heard I
came from Delphi and people are saying
Delphi you're still doing Delphi you
poor poor bastard why are you doing
Delphi well the rosettes a comet is
actually has software written in Delphi
and you know what Delphi is still being
used and people are writing applications
that impact people's lives in a good way
right by saving lives I'm not talking
about you know things that track how
many steps your dog makes when it does
exercises with you actually changing
people's lives and then we make fun of
things like this like jasonang X is an
IBM standard format to represent JSON as
XML I mean you've got a laugh you see
that and you're like what the hell like
why why would someone want to represent
JSON as XML you know why it's actually
for a security proxy because it's
cheaper to do it that way it is cheaper
to interrupt with that with a
ACK than it is to have to rewrite
everything right but we don't look at
these things but you say no but to sip
you see it's not so much about that is
that we need to attract new talent right
no one's gonna come and say oh you want
a job in delphi actually now if you're a
good consultant in delphi you're gonna
make a lot of money right because you
know the pond shrinks and the fish
become bigger there's good money in
COBOL as well I hear this is what we put
on our CDs isn't it I know angularjs I
know really at what it's not I was Duran
Don that's called irelia react jQuery
JavaScript Java closure c-sharp VB
sequel server MongoDB this is what we
put this is what we look for we don't
say oh you know I have a brain and I
know software engineering principles
which can't be said unfortunately for
quite a anyway experience I've saved you
know millions of lines of code writing
software to cut our bureaucratic cross
we don't explain what we've done we
focus on what technologies we know right
and how many of you actually here want
to be valued based on your tech stack
probably no one because you know that
when a new technology comes along you'll
easily learn it right because
technologies come and go right we've all
learned multiple technologies and we can
continue to learn multiple technologies
we're in one of those jobs which we
exercise I are brained continuously and
we're fortunate enough to be able to do
that so why are we so obsessed with I
need to put c-sharp on my CV we are
feeding the same cycle that is
backfiring on us right we need to be on
the cutting edge I'm not denying that we
need to learn we need to come to
conferences we need to look up new
technologies we need to evaluate these
technologies but we also need to
question when and why to adopt these
technologies and we shouldn't adopt it
based on hype you know or hype driven
development there are people that
actually choose packages technologies
based on github Forks and stars there
are right you go to an NPM what's the
first thing you do you go to the gate
package and say how many Forks does it
have why in case the original developer
drops support you're gonna go to the
fourth version how many times do you do
that
hardly ever you and moan and say
oh this this is no longer maintained or
are you doing adoption based on
technology radars or as I said earlier
thought leaders you know everyone
everyone has a reason to say everything
even me right so always take things with
a pinch of salt and then of course
there's the adoption based on assumed
correlation you know Netflix adopted
micro-services Netflix is successful
therefore we should have got married
micro-services are you doing hive video
streaming to millions of people
worldwide and doing all of these other
things like catalog display and sets or
Microsoft no why it's quite cool that I
heard that so is a bowl of mud
micro-services is really cool
yes have they told you about all of the
maintainability nightmare that goes into
micro services no but I can log stuff
and look at it in a beautiful panel and
see things go back and forth it's
brilliant right you know that in 2013
uber migrated from my sequel to Postgres
sequel right in July 2016
uber switched from Postgres to my sequel
yes just something to take into account
when you adopt technology based on
others and the reality is that we really
have a lot of potential you know we are
in a in ever evolving field where we are
given the opportunity to constantly be
learning and improving ourselves right
so why waste it on hype and why take our
talents are wasted on effortless things
that no one's gonna appreciate and it's
not gonna actually change or impact
anyone's lives and yet we have the
potential to do that we really do I mean
how many other jobs in the world
actually can impact people's lives for
the better
very few and we're in that field that is
constantly challenging us right so let's
just focus on the right things ok so now
go learn and
by everything without judgment thank you